I'm not crazy that's what I aim to
determine now let's begin what is your
name you know my name please answer the
question
my name is all hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my arrow
episode 4 video a very Clockwork Orange
type of episode at least from Oliver's
perspective but we got all kinds of
flash-forwards and a whole bunch of
details revealed about what happens to
people in the future there's a new round
of that DC streaming service giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video obviously careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet top 10 WTF and Easter eggs here we
go number 10
Oliver wakes up in level 2 in his full
Clockwork Orange Green Arrow this week
Jeremy Carver is the psychiatrist
working on level 2 he seems fairly
genuine in his mission to try and reform
Oliver Queen
but he's treating the Green Arrow is
sort of a symptom of a larger problem
throwing his father under the bus so if
you haven't seen Stanley Kubrick's
Clockwork Orange it's an amazing movie
but it's basically the same path like
slowly breaking down and reforming
someone that he thinks is a dangerous
criminal but the interesting thing about
the message of that movie is is all
about free will so this is just another
challenge for Oliver to try and maintain
his identity while he's going through
all this number 9 Felicity starts to go
hilariously dark when she's
interrogating that longbow hunter there
were a couple funny moments with black
siren where she talks about earth to
Felicity o-mai Felicity Brennan Empire
but she was ruthless are you prepared to
be ruthless like how dark are you going
to get in your mission to try and save
Oliver and help the city there were a
couple references that old Roy made in
the flash-forwards - things going really
badly and seemingly kind of bitter about
something that Felicity may do in the
future this might have something to do
with the path that she's are just
implying that she does go pretty dark
but number 8 the new Green Arrow saves
wild dogs daughter from an attack this
sort of sets up a larger plot that they
pay off in the flash-forwards with
people going around setting fires in the
glades just randomly blowing things up
then buying the real estate on the cheap
it wouldn't be a new season of arrow if
someone were trying to burn down the
glades remember that was the whole thing
that Malcolm Merlyn was trying to do
with the undertaking destroy the glades
so that they could clean it up and
turned it into something nicer the way
they set up this new criminal group
that's going around setting all these
fires makes it a little
more sinister though especially when you
find out what ends up happening in the
future I did like wild dogs reaction to
the Bebo Easter egg why are you bringing
that in here she's way too old for that
that's ridiculous
the other shows now in the arrowverse
had tried to keep that Bebo joke alive
where it just pops up on other people's
shows every once in a while 7 the
psychiatrist doses Oliver with true
serum forcing him to relive a lot of his
memories from the pilot like he has to
go back into the moment when his father
killed himself in that life raft and
this is all part of the larger storyline
for season 7 examining Oliver's legacy
as the green arrow with William
obviously they directly reference that
during the episode but in this moment
it's through the lens of Oliver's father
like the legacy he's left you he's put
all these sins on you trapped you in
this never-ending cycle of torture that
you're unable to move forward from duly
noted the psychiatrist not a big fan of
Oliver's father the other thing they
start referencing to is the idea of the
name Queen Oliver Queen my name is
Oliver Queen at the beginning of the
episode Oliver's father killing the
guard because he wasn't part of the
Queen family earliest as the
psychiatrist implies that's all part of
the larger storyline the legacy of Green
Arrow and that's also has something to
do with the brand new Green Arrow you
know the mystery person that we haven't
figured out yet but you may have heard
there was actually a big reveal a couple
weeks ago I didn't do an arrow video
last week but it actually has since been
revealed or at least implied who the new
Green Arrow is I won't say here because
it is kind of spoilery and it hasn't
been officially revealed yet but if you
start to look at some of the clues in
the references that they lay into their
dialog like talking about the legacy of
Oliver's father the Queen name all these
things you can start to put the pieces
together please be careful about posting
spoilers in the comments but if you're a
big Green Arrow comic book fan it's
gonna be a big easter egg from the
comics so you'll be really happy about
that 6 felicity joking about black siren
not being a real lawyer this is
something that I've thought about since
last season like how are they gonna
justify her pretending to be a lawyer
like she actually does have to practice
law in her job black sirens reaction is
sort of the writers just joking about it
tongue and cheek like yeah yeah yeah
let's move on to the next thing but they
have a good laugh about it they make a
good pair together but the whole reason
that black siren is there is to
I tried it like shake some sense into
Felicity like look I have killed a lot
of people and I can tell you you're
never gonna come back from this if you
torture this girl too much so which is
more of them implying that Felicity
might go super dark in the future that
leads to some of the chaos that you see
in those flash forwards with old William
and old Roy but number five old Roy and
William enter Smoak technologies so
obviously this is just paying off the
storyline that they initially teased I
think it started during legends of
tomorrow and then they did it again
during the arrow 100th episode where
Oliver was in that dream state you see
the building in the background but it's
again like black sirens says the
felicity of Earth to created this Empire
with Smoak technologies but her felicity
over on that earth was crazy dark so the
whole reason that they're there and all
this wreckage because the city has just
gone to complete [ __ ] they even joke
about that too like wow it's just as bad
as I remember it but the whole reason
why they're there is is because someone
that they think is Felicity Smoak has
been using the hozen to lead them around
it wants them to get this special
Rubik's Cube map that Felicity seemingly
left behind we finally get to meet the
older version of Black Canary who has
become a vigilante again looks a little
battle war she represented they're all
really vague about the bad things that
happened but then you get the full
explainer a little bit later in the
episode four they finally go full
Clockwork Orange on Oliver hooking him
up to that special dream machine making
him relive his father's death through
the life raft only altering at this time
so that Oliver's perceiving it as if it
were him and William that were stuck in
there and he's the person to kill
himself in a perfect world I would use
that as the thumbnail just because it
would give everybody a heart attack but
YouTube would D monetize my video
immediately but it's probably one of the
most incendiary like fake scenes that
they've ever done like oh my gosh Oliver
Queen and he's killing himself this is
crazy
three Black Canary finally comes around
on the new Korean arrow after she helps
them take down all those thugs that were
trying to blow up the theater
this is them just paying off that Black
Canary art within the episode I'm glad
they didn't drag it on longer because
you never really liked it when team
arrow is fighting itself we did that
last season and it was really unpopular
so this is her just coming around doing
it Quentin style like bending
the rules when it was necessary but
number two big WTF
Oliver is seemingly broken and
reprogrammed by this mental device
that's what his response was meant to
imply because at the beginning of the
episode the psychiatrist says what's
your name and he says my name is Oliver
Queen that's one of the cornerstones of
the intros that they do in each episode
my name is Oliver Queen
but now after he's been in this mental
device he says what is your name he says
my name is inmate four or five eight
seven implying that he might be broken
it's the exact same thing they did
during season five when Prometheus was
raking him over the coals over all of
his past perceived misdeeds so number
one biggest reveal though what is
happening in the future
Black Canary reveals that it couldn't be
Felicity that's been leading them around
with that hosen because Felicity in this
future timeline is supposed to be dead
and they revealed that the city really
went to [ __ ] when the glades built a
wall around because things had gotten so
bad
so it gives you an idea for what the
criminals in the past were trying to do
trying to buy up all that real estate
trying to create the circumstances that
would allow them to turn the glades into
a self-contained fortress that they
could control they were pretty on the
nose with their political metaphors like
what does build a wall around it remind
you of we also get to meet the older
version of Zoe that looks like she's
either become a new version of a black
canary or just another vigilante we
don't know what her codename is but
she's wearing a mask that looks exactly
like black Canary's mask but obviously
the big teaser for the future episodes
is you know who is the person that's
been leading old Roy and William around
what I'm hoping is is that this mystery
person in the future is also the mystery
Green Arrow and present-day so they'll
like sort of solve both of those at the
same time when they reveal who it is let
me know in the comments what was your
favorite WTF moment and if you spotted
any Easter eggs that I didn't mention in
the video there's no flash tomorrow
because there's an election happening in
the United States but it'll be back the
week after that there was a new Captain
Marvel promo that just dropped so I'll
probably do a video for that tomorrow
this is really fun Easter Egg click here
for that new flash trailer and another
crossover teaser and click here to learn
all about X Men in Black Panther - thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
I'll see you
tonight
[Music]